wie bitte es gab keinen urknall davon
geht jedenfalls die kosmologen
dr elias aus stattdessen meint sie dass
es sich um einen kosmos handelt der sich
ständig selbst recycelt wenn das stimmt
müssen unsere bücher neu geschrieben
werden und sogar führende astronomen
halten die theorie für plausibel what
klicks konstanz und fiktion hier gibt's
täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst er nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen aus unseren
lehrbüchern wissen wir dass unser
universum von 13,8 milliarden jahren mit
dem urknall begonnen hat doch die
theoretische physikerin dr anna elias
hat eine andere these sie arbeitet in
den bereichen gravitation und kosmologie
als forschungs gruppenleiterin am max
planck institut für gravitationsphysik
dem albert einstein institut in hannover
in ihren studien untersucht sie die
grundlegenden fragen des universums und
erforscht wie sich in zukunft entwickeln
wird sie hat an den universitäten
princeton colombia und harvard geforscht
und sowohl in physik als auch in
philosophie promoviert vielleicht liegen
hier auch deshalb extreme und mutige
theorien jetzt hat sie ein szenario
entwickelt das erst mal ziemlich skurril
klingen sie nimmt an dass unser
universum nicht durch den urknall
entstanden ist sondern nur eine neue
version eines viel älteren kosmos ist
vielleicht sogar die dritte oder vierte
oder sechste version davon
denn wie viele es schon gewesen sein
können kann sie nicht genau sagen diese
theorie entstand aus einem guten wurden
zitat das modell nach dem der urknall
der anfang von allem sei wirft einige
probleme auf ja das sagt die expertin
damit meinen sie vor allem das konzept
der kosmischen inflation das beschreibt
eine über licht schnelle ausdehnung des
alls besonders schnell direkt nach dem
urknall und nur wenige
sekundenbruchteile dauerte dieser ganz
heftige effekt ist wurde in den 80er
jahren entwickelt und erklärt warum
unser universum ein simples und
gleichförmiges ganzes ergibt hätte es
sich nämlich nur langsam ausgedehnt
würden die zufälligen quanten
schwankungen des urknalls gebiete mit
unterschiedlicher energiedichte bilden
diese würden astrophysiker und
physikerin bis heute in der verteilung
der markt
und der raumzeit erkennen als gebirge
und teller doch von denen ist nichts zu
sehen
mit der inflations theorie wurde also
das fehlen dieser unebenheiten durch die
schnelle ausdehnung des universums
erklärt diese erklärung hat willi es
jedoch deutliche lücken und diese lücken
konnten sie nicht mehr hinnehmen als
2013 die daten des plank satelliten
veröffentlichten wurden dabei wurde die
kosmische hintergrundstrahlung mit noch
nie dagewesener genauigkeit vermessen
das bild dass dabei vom universum
geliefert wurde sei für einige varianten
der informationstheorie einfach zu
simpel da jegliche spur von primor die
gravitation zu empfehlen
das sind winzige gleichförmige
schwankungen in der raumzeit die ein
eindeutiger hinweis auf die inflationäre
ausdehnung des universums sein sollen
gegen die inflations theorie spricht
auch dass sie nur unter sehr speziellen
anfangsbedingungen starten kann
und genau diese vorgaben seien ziemlich
unwahrscheinlich stocks elias arbeitet
deshalb an einer besseren erklärung
diese erklärung ist ein zyklisches
universum ein universum das sich
ausdehnt und dann wieder zusammenzieht
und das immer wieder aufs neue
statt einem urknall gab es also eher
eine nur prall und davon vielleicht
sogar schon mehrere doch wie sie das
genau aus unser heutiges universum ist
10 hoch 28 zentimeter groß das ist eine
zahl mit 29 stellen und 28 0 neben also
wirklich riesig nach elias denen es sich
noch etwa 100 milliarden jahre lang aus
um dann wieder zu schrumpfen auf die
größe der milchstraße dann unseres
sonnensystems dann unserer erde eines
fußballs eines virus und so weiter bis
es nur noch ungefähr zehn hoch minus 25
zentimeter klein ist also wirklich
ziemlich ziemlich ziemlich ziemlich
klein und dann fängt alles wieder von
vorne an
bei der zahl 10 hoch minus 25 zentimeter
zu sich erst nach 25 stellen nach dem
komma etwas also da kommt überhaupt die
erste zahl ein winzig kleines universum
also aber immer noch größer als ein
universum das durch einen urknall
entsteht ganz am anfang seiner
entstehung wäre die witzigeren setzt
dabei auf eine abwandlung der
einsteinschen fällt gleich um demnach
würde sich ein universum das sich
zusammenzieht gerade rechtzeitig wieder
aussehen bevor es das gebiet der
beschreibbaren physik verlässt
das muss man sich fragen wie ein sich
aus denen des universum eines tages
anfängt wieder zusammen zu schrumpfen
ein grund dafür könnte zum beispiel der
verfall dunkler energie seien dunkle
energie ist der effekt mit dem sie die
beschleunigte ausdehnung des universums
erklärt je mehr sich das universum
zusammen zieht desto größer wird der
druck in ihm dieser druck verhindert
dann dass es sich so sehr verkleinert
wie eben ein urknall kosmos außerdem
sorgt er dafür dass so etwas wie klumpen
in der energieverteilung und raum zeit
entstehen können
das erklärt warum eine inflation nicht
mehr nötig ist weil der neue cross man
sich von anfang an relativ gleichförmig
entwickelt so weit die theorie
in fachkreisen wird sie heftig
kritisiert und jetzt muss die kosmologen
starke beweise liefern um ihre gewagten
these zu stützen
in der mathematischen beschreibung hat
sie bereits fortschritte erzielt der
nächste schritt wäre eine computer
simulation des urknalls die ilias in ein
bis zwei jahren präsentieren möchte
damit hätte sie wohl die chance wirklich
ernst genommen zu werden schließlich ist
es durchaus möglich dass bisherige
annahme auch fehlerhaft sein könnten
torsten enßlin ein führender forscher
der planck mission sagte selbst dass
beide theorien urknall und uhr prallt
gewagte annahmen zur energieformen
machen und das ist nicht
unwahrscheinlich sei dass dabei etwas
schief gehe außerdem ist da noch paul
steinhart eine instanz der kosmologie
aus princeton der die inflations theorie
selbst mitentwickelt hat sich aber
schließlich davon distanziert hat er ist
selbst zum verfechter des ur prall
modells geworden und hat dr ließ dazu
ermutigt offen für alternativen zu
bleiben es bleibt also spannend bis wir
wissen ob unser kosmos irgendwann wieder
auf die größe eines virus zusammen
schrumpfen könnte und ob wir die
geschichte des universums neu schreiben
müssen vom urknall zum leeren raum
anklicken anschauen und unbedingt
hyperraum tv abonnieren
richtig klasse kanal bis dann bleibt
dran